so how's the new year been treating you
it was a wild 2022 and with more of 2023
on the horizon I bet you're excited for
the next batches of anime Seasons that
we're getting last year I already made a
video on what I think are some of the
titles that you'll be excited for in the
coming years and let's narrow that
timeline down a little bit now in this
video I'll solely be focusing on action
anime that have been confirmed for a
2023 release so strap yourselves in and
sit back for the ride as we try to do a
quick run through of 2023 and some
action anime to get excited for dead
Mound death play starts off the list
[Music]
and here we have an isakai kicking
things off but it's not the traditional
one as you'd expect it's a reverse
issachite where the Necromancer in his
final Gambit reincarnates himself into
our world it's kind of similar to a
devil as a part-timer premise but the
similarities pretty much in there dead
Mount death play takes things to the
deeper end having a dark story that
shows us the less glamorous side of
modern society Yakuza fights the police
gang Chasers assassins you get the
picture don't you it's a pretty solid
story from what I've seen so far and I
like how the world gets set up with
poker that's our Necromancer protagonist
and his new identity coming to grips
with the world he's found himself in as
well as how his magic interacts with it
it's a story that plays with the usual
fantasy and reincarnation tropes and one
it may at first seem like a premise
that's been done before as I've said
it's got a more chaotic and edgy feel to
it a lot of interwoven plots and such as
expected of the writer ryogo Narita who
you may know as the guy behind durarara
foreign
skill in another world and became
unrivaled in the real world too is the
next show on the list
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a mouthful of a title there the
isakai genre the key words like cheat
you know where this is headed don't you
but before this gets brushed off as just
another isakai this title doesn't have a
Nifty twist to it if you still haven't
guessed from the title it's about
bullied boy yuya tenjo who finds a door
to another world there he finds a world
of Treasure of magic of all the things
he ever wanted but why stay in that
other world like most issakai
protagonists why confine yourself when
you can bring everything back to the
real world and start anew being the best
version of yourself it's something that
really plays to The Escapist themes of
the isakai genre only now much more
overt about it how could that be anyway
being able to just go to the fantasy
world and come back reinvent yourself
and be the best and strongest you ever
wanted to be this series obviously
targets a specific Niche but if you're
into it this might be to your liking
yesterday
a lot of times we get caught up watching
anime don't you wish that you had easy
access to some delicious food by your
side introducing the sponsors of this
video Tokyo treat and sakurako a double
header of subscription-based snack boxes
I'll give you the Japan experience in
the Comforts of your own home sakurako
is the one that you'd want to go for if
you're up for some artisan and authentic
Japanese Snacks by your side this
month's box lets you celebrate the new
year with the collaboration with nigata
prefecture and its best snack makers
with the year of the rabbit coming up
you get some awesome sweets headed your
way I personally love this crap here you
know what else is included a sake cup
perfect for cheers and drinking liquor
the Japan way however if you prefer
something more modern a more seasonal
Tokyo treat might be the thing for you
this snack box specializes in the latest
and most exclusive snacks that you can
get from Japan or by emphasizing the
concept of cool Japan he wants some
proof how about this spy family candy
featuring Anya since that anime is all
the rage in the world right now don't
forget to use my code Vinnie to get five
dollars off your first box and check
this out a possible trip to Japan now
ain't that cool you can check out the
link in the description for more details
and thank you once again for sponsoring
the video Tokyo treat and sakurako
another title I'm on the lookout for is
Undead unluck
now here's a unique premise although not
something too foreign if you're a fan of
fairy tale Undead unlock tells the story
of Fuko izumo probably the unluckiest
person alive here's the catch though
anyone she touches gets stricken with
the worst fortunes possible even
indirectly resulting in their deaths
that's why she's so eager to end her own
existence until one day she encounters
Andy a death Seeker like herself and he
is an immortal someone who's a perfect
match for izumo's constant stream of
Misfortune izumo decides to help Andy
get the most appropriate end possible
but little do they know that a
mysterious organization lurks in the
shadows looking to take advantage of
their strange Powers what kind of
Misadventures await this unlikely Duo
watch Undead and luck to find out
[Music]
foreign
we take the fantasy aspects further with
the title at number seven Ragnar crimson
[Music]
Ragnar Crimson takes us more to the
traditional fantasy world that we've
grown to love this is a world where
dragons roared and Mankind must band
together in order to fight against said
rulers our protagonist the Dragon Hunter
Ragnar takes the lead with his eyes on
victory victory at all cost even if it
means allying with the mysterious
Crimson however power comes at a price
and that may be something that Ragnar
might not be prepared for now here's an
anime for those who love the good old
high fantasy RPGs Ragnar Crimson as a
manga has a lot of things going for it
it's got some really great fights and
the artwork just makes it look way more
spectacular than it had any right to be
great story progression too and when the
stakes are high you really feel it so
now it's time to see if or translate
well into an anime format but I'm not
worried about this one after all
silverlink will be doing the anime
they've done a pretty good job a lot of
the shows I've enjoyed so I think the
series is in good hands we've also got a
lot of people from Demon Slayer and
Jujutsu Kaizen involved so get ready for
some insane battle scenes down the line
I need see nothing
so
now
number six is Shangri-La Frontier
have you ever felt that motivation that
urge to just clear video games no matter
how terrible they are you'll probably
hit it up well with rakuro who makes it
agree to find all the awful games from
the bottom of the barrel and clearing
them with his unparalleled gaming skills
deciding to play a good game for once he
comes across this new MMO Shangri-La
Frontier seems to be nothing more than a
tiny roadblock for him to run over so we
jump straight into the action and looks
to max out his stats never mind the
prologue and background however skill as
he may be you may have found his match
in Shangri-La Frontier perhaps it's now
that he's got to dig deep into his
experience of playing all those terrible
games in order to uncover the secrets
behind Shangri-La Frontier this is
gaming anime done in a really
entertaining way the world's well
thought out I like how the title shares
some aspects of gaming culture in a
tongue-in-cheek way if you're someone
who spent a substantial amount playing
games and interacting with others in
MMOs the show can have a lot of things
for you to enjoy stuff that you can
relate to even
next we have Marshall at number five
[Music]
one punch Man meets Harry Potter as so
many have said Marshall is um quite the
unique spectacle being tagged as a
threat that must be eliminated young
Mash burned it turns to battling magic
itself how does he do it he trains his
body to become strong enough to overcome
magic and when his secret gets exposed
he only turns to forcing the world to
acknowledge his existence thus begins
his Adventure at Eastern magic Academy
where he competes with the best of the
best the magical Mash may seem
handicapped but with his training and
fists he looks to break through all
those challenges and become the Divine
Visionary people have called these Magic
School anime Harry Potter derivatives
but I haven't seen an anime that looks
so similar yet Marshall's one of those
manga that took quite a while to pick up
it's done really well for itself with
its endearing Underdog Story and comedy
that Harkens back to one's work if
you're out for some final magic action
this 2023 you're definitely going to
want to check this one out
foreign
[Music]
Blades of the Guardians
[Music]
it's been a while but by our end Blades
of the Guardians is finally ready to hit
the screens set in the sui Dynasty the
story tells of people struggling to live
under the rule of the terrible Emperor
Yang Guang in order to avoid being
pursued by the Imperial Court our
protagonist who is a master swordsman
takes on an escort Mission the end goal
of this perilous Quest the capital
changan with salvation await him at the
end of The Journey or will it lead to
Doom amidst the political chaos in China
coming off a really great manwa the
anime adaptation seems like it will take
you further with insane animation
stunning visuals and overall great
production values the PBS have looked
really good and look like they could
give you for table a run for their money
and I bet fans will appreciate the
amount of love and work that God put
into it
foreign
third of the most anticipated action
anime is Hell's Paradise
[Music]
what do you do with a guy that just
refuses to die same question puzzle the
one who was set to execute Gabi Maru the
hollow betrayed and sent to death row
Gabi model just wouldn't die but with
such a freak of nature as a possible
asset he gets offered a chance of
Salvation that is if he can survive the
treacherous Island that's said to
contain the elixir of life so Begins the
journey that will test Gabi maru's metal
to the Limit with hazards in the island
and inmates for partners that he's not
sure he can trust danger lurks
everywhere in this journey but for the
sake of Salvation and a new life with
his loved ones there's little that can
stop Gabi Maru the hollow the hit shown
in Jump Plus title finally gets his
chance to shine as an anime and it's
coming this 2023
[Music]
talk to you
oh
at number two is a Timeless classic
Rurouni Kenshin
Rurouni Kenshin has been one of the most
enduring Legacy titles out there
numerous spin-offs a handful of
supplementary material live action
adaptations that were actually good the
ball keeps rolling in 2023 as we'll be
getting a remake of the original series
as for my opinions on this series I
don't think it's a remake that we really
needed considering how good most of what
we already have is however the 90s
series did leave us hanging due to it
being canceled after filler hell perhaps
with this new iteration of the series we
can have the more complete version of
Rurouni Kenshin old fans seem very
excited to see Kenshin make a grand
return in anime form and here's to
hoping we get a lot of new fans to enjoy
the story of the wandering swordsman and
his path to Redemption
I'm gonna say
however the excitement for ruroni
Kenshin pales in comparison to the
number one most anticipated action anime
of 2023 it's solo leveling
[Applause]
[Music]
it's finally here for years fans have
begged for an animated adaptation of one
of the most popular webtoons out there
there was hope when all those webtoons
were getting adapted in 2020 then
nothing no solo leveling at all however
it didn't take long for the fans to get
their wish as this hit webtoon will
finally hit our screens in 2023 it's
super popular as a series and I think
people who love stories that feature a
protagonist overcoming things and going
from weak to overpowered would love this
anime sung jinwoo's immersive and gritty
tale of going through Dungeons and
overcoming the strongest monsters could
in a way give some flashbacks to titles
like Ari fioreto with A1 pictures
Manning the helm in this adaptation and
familiar names like hiroyuki sawano
involved they've really planned this to
be a big scale production and I don't
think it's gonna disappoint
[Applause]
so with that I wrap up with what I think
are the top 10 action anime for you to
be excited about the floors open if you
have any other shows that you're looking
forward to if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to leave a like and a
subscription thank you for watching and
I'll see you next time this year is just
getting started and we'll have a lot
more anime lists coming your way so be
sure to stay tuned